(school bells chiming)
(bell ringing)
(people talking quietly)
(school bells chiming)
(people clapping)
(bell ringing)
(school bells chiming)
(people clapping)
- [Student] Go Hopper!
(people cheering)
(school bells chiming)
(people talking quietly)
(people cheering)
(bell ringing)
(school bells chiming)
(people talking quietly)
(indistinct speaking)
- How could you forget that?
- I don't know.
(school bells chiming)
(people speaking quietly)
(classical music)
(people cheering)
- Let me first unmute myself.
Good morning, Yale College Class of 2021.
(people cheering)
Welcome to the graduates of
Grace Hopper, Jonathan Edwards,
Trumbull, Silliman,
and Ezra Stiles College
who have arrived on Old
Campus to begin our ceremony,
and welcome to family, friends
and members of the class
who are joining us virtually
today via livestream.
We are so excited to have
arrived on this special day.
In a few moments we will
begin announcing the graduates
as they process across
the commencement stage
here in front of me.
Before we start our program,
a few words about the land
on which today's ceremony is taking place.
Yale acknowledges that
indigenous peoples and nations
including Mohegan, Mashantucket
Pequot, Eastern Pequot,
Schaghticoke, Golden
Hill Paugussett, Niantic,
and the Quinnipiac and other
Algonquin-speaking peoples
have stewarded through generations
the lands and waterways
of what is now the state of Connecticut.
We honor and respect the
enduring relationship that exists
between these peoples and
nations and this land.
Thank you and please enjoy the program.
(people clapping)
- Okay.
Mr. President, I have the honor to present
candidates from Trumbull College
for the Bachelor's
degrees in Yale College.
When they have been
recommended by the faculty
of Yale College and
approved by the corporation,
Dean Chun will ask you
by your official act
to confer upon them these degrees.
(people cheering)
- By the authority vested in
me, I shall confer upon you
the Bachelor's degrees in Yale College,
when designated by the dean,
and shall then admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities.
- Jeffrey Zhou, the banner
bearer of Trumbull College.
Claire Lamarre and Marcus Sak,
the procession marshals
of Trumbull College.
Obed Kwasi Ashiatey Ababio.
Donald Ahrens.
Tiffany Bolade Alowashione Ajumobi.
Jacob Dean Asher.
Gianna Baez.
Jeremy Baron.
Sarah Brakebill-Hacke.
Sam Brigham.
Darrion Colby Carrington.
Cal Christofori.
Dayle Chung.
Caleb Cohen.
Vinicius Da Silva.
Aki Dhadda.
Cece Gao.
Hannah Geller.
Lauren Gillinov.
Xinwei Danny Guo.
Yashasvini Jindal.
Zeynep Karacan.
Adia Klein.
Hunter Kohn.
Kathryn Kozey.
Tahj Phillip Lakey.
Abigail Leonard.
Alan Liu.
Hannah Manz.
Mitchell Mares.
Celia Martinez-Aceves.
Jack Mattei.
Gabriella Mencio.
Riya Mital.
Caroline Moore.
Jewel Moore.
Vishnu Murale.
Jonathan Murillo.
Grant Neagli.
Obidike Nnorom, Jr.
Max Obmascik.
Ilayda Orhan.
Jiyoon Park.
Ruchira Ray.
Zyria Jennea Rodgers.
Mariko Fujimoto Rooks.
Melvin Rouse.
Nicholas Andrés Ruiz-Huidobro Magdits.
Daniel Sanchez.
Johanna Shen.
Jeremy Robert Irwin Sontchi.
Ricardo Aaron Soto.
Charles Tananbaum.
Griffin Coolidge Thomas.
Rodney Thomas II.
Jared Guang-Cheng Truong.
Peter Vanderslice.
Ava Vanech.
Anushka Walia.
Angelica Walker.
Alexander Whittaker.
Adam Wolnikowski.
Christopher Xue.
Eric Youshao.
Jingjia Jerry Zhou.
And Benjamin Zolkiewicz.
Congratulations, Trumbullians. Moo-rah!
(people cheering)
- Mr. President, I have
the honor to present
candidates from Grace Hopper College
for the Bachelor's
degrees in Yale College.
When they have been
recommended by the faculty
of Yale College and
approved by the corporation,
Dean Chun will ask you
by your official act
to confer upon them these degrees.
(people cheering)
- By the authority vested in
me, I shall confer upon you
the Bachelor's degrees in Yale College,
when designated by the dean,
and shall than admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities.
(people clapping)
- Shujun Zhao, the banner
bearer of Grace Hopper College.
Jau Tung Chan and Megan Xinei Xu,
the procession marshals
of Grace Hopper College.
Abdah Haroon Adam.
Megan Marie Ahern.
Aia Alvarez Nishio.
Kofi Ansong.
Malik Markane Barnett.
Ryan Elisabeth Benson.
Alma Maia Bitran.
Seungkyoon Antonio Bong.
Timothy Carter Bradley.
Eleazar Camez.
Ko Lyn Cheang.
Xinyi Chen.
Patrick Andrés Cherry.
Rachel Allegra Cohen.
John Harmon Cooper.
Robert Sebastian Crystal.
Formosa Deppman.
Samuel Harris Essig.
Rian Ann Eversole.
Julien Mateo Fernandez.
Indira Amani Flores.
Charles Bernard Foster.
Drew Galls.
Neehaar Jayesh Gandhi.
Michael Edward Garvey.
Lauren Gatta.
Zachary Jason Gold.
Vivek Yadhu Gopalan.
Meher Hans.
Valente Hernandez-Bautista.
Yvonne Ho.
Robert James Shearman Howard.
JJ Howland.
Charlotte Anne Hylinski.
Talus Gardiner Iorio-Ronek.
Rayshawn Antoine Johnson, Jr.
Olivia Danielle Jorasch.
Samuel Landino.
Sophie Elspeth Morton Latham.
Paige Julia Lawrence.
Melissa Leone.
Marlika Altagracia Marceau.
Michael Martinez.
John Krishan Bir Maypole.
Julia Catherine McClellan.
Dalia Moallem.
Matt Scott Nadel.
Julia Nadelmann.
Larissa Hana Nguyen.
Crystal Lynn Nieves Garcia.
Zoe Elizabeth Nuechterlein.
Alejandro Nuno.
Darrell Luis-Manuel Pona.
Dean Perseveranda Putong.
Anshuman Radhakrishnan.
Reese Roberts.
Nissim Roffe.
D. Major Roman.
Miriam Aviva Ross.
Annika Kaarina Salmi.
Kathryn Wright Schmechel.
Brandon David Scott.
Shaima Buyon Shama.
Chiara Nicole Spain.
Aarohi Srivastava.
Simon Lee Stone.
Erik Kenji Takada.
Teava Marco Torres De Sa.
Lin Thandar Tun.
Rianna Marie Turner.
Alondra Olimpia Vazquez Lopez.
Clara Penteado.
Nancy Kathryn Walecki.
Eric Wallach.
Carly Wanna.
Cory Wu.
Vivian Yi.
Amber Paschal Young.
Jordan Craig Young.
Daniel Zhao.
And the graduates who are
participating remotely.
(upbeat music)
Congratulations Grace Hopper
College class of 2021.
(people applauding)
- Mr. President, I have
the honor to present
candidates from Jonathan Edwards College
for the Bachelor's
degrees in Yale College.
When they have been
recommended by the faculty
of Yale College and
approved by the corporation,
Dean Chun will ask you
by your official act
to confer upon them these degrees.
(people cheering)
- By the authority vested in
me, I shall confer upon you
the Bachelor's degrees in Yale College,
when designated by the dean,
and shall than admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities.
- Anna J. Sun, the banner bearer
of Jonathan Edwards College.
Chimasoka-Chika Victory Ogbejesi
and Steven Daniel Orientale,
the procession marshals of
Jonathan Edwards College.
Fiona Aileen Asbury.
Ekaterine Bakradze.
Jacey Cacal Baldovino.
Darnell Battle.
Nathalie Beauchamps.
Griffin Bowen Berlin.
Lydia Burleson.
Aakshi Chaba.
Simarpreet Singh Chadha.
Mari Mekhi Chiles.
Chiara Michal Na-Ri Chung-Halpern.
McKenzie Marie Cooke.
Kaitlyn Nicole Corfman.
Katherine Livingston Cutler.
Nicholas Bayard Cutler, Jr.
Raajii Choroke Daniel.
Kate Maureen Donovan.
Dustin Kent Dunaway.
Lena H. Gallager.
Markos Gazepis.
Alina Jennifer Mila Glaubitz.
Mia Nkechi Jackson.
Gregory Jany.
Kit Yee Kan.
Anna Sophia Kane.
Jake Lawrence Kalodner.
Matthew Joseph Lamirande.
Johnny Nguyen Le.
Taesoo Daniel Lee.
Kevin Ji Li.
Heidi Makhlouf.
Charles Paul Markert.
Diego Martell.
Samantha J. Martinelli.
Nicholas Chandler Marwell.
Alexandra Nicole McCraven.
Luke Ian McKenna.
Jillian Eve Mehlman.
Clara Rose Molot.
Lauren Moriyama.
Hang Phuong Nguyen.
Jesutomi Odukoya.
Cristina Beatriz Otero.
Jessica Taylor Pevner.
Nguyen Khoi Pham.
Tuan Bao Chau Pham.
Lily Cornelia Brainard Rogers.
Nicholas Victor Serrambana.
Aditi Krishni Shetty.
Calvin Blake Solomon.
Saphia Suarez.
Alexa Sabrina Tsay.
Vera Chung Villanueva.
Miles Xavier Waits.
Emma Luisa Wilson.
Wai Pan Wong.
Angela Xiao.
Alice Zhao.
And the graduates participating remotely.
(upbeat music)
Congratulations, JE class of 2021.
(people cheering)
- Mr. President, I have
the honor to present
candidates from Silliman College
for the Bachelor's
degrees in Yale College.
When they have been
recommended by the faculty
of Yale College and
approved by the corporation,
Dean Chun will ask you
by your official act
to confer upon them these degrees.
(people cheering)
- By the authority vested in
me, I shall confer upon you
the Bachelor's degrees in Yale College,
when designated by the dean,
and shall than admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities.
- Brooke Catherine Milosh,
the banner bearer of Silliman College.
Camila Andrea Toro and Cory Mark Zhou,
the procession marshals
of Silliman College.
Se Bin Ahn.
Samir Al-Ali.
Avery L. Arena.
Aurora Taylor Asadorian.
Jyot Singh Batra.
Daniel Matthew Blatt.
Natalie Jane Boyer.
Emma Marie Brodey.
Joseph Antonio Brownsberger.
Brenda Sophia Cachay Gutierrez.
Chelsea Maria Chaug.
Kevin Chen.
Kathryn D. Clulo.
Jesus Contreras Magana.
Andre L. Costa.
John Dean.
Olivia Drubner.
Farah Marie Emory-Muhammad.
Darlene Luzmaria Gomez.
Kenia Danelle Hale.
Deonte Damond Henson.
Samantha Higgins.
Stephanie Boma Horsfall.
Lillian Hua.
Jacob Koppelman Hutt.
Robert William Jahrling.
Brett William Jewell.
Anthony Liang Ji.
Sungmi Anna Johnson.
Christina Kao.
Conor Jacob Kennedy.
JP Kenney.
Emery David Kerekes.
Caroline Sohyun Kim.
Lauren Kim.
Nikita Klimenko.
Aline Soochung Ko.
Madelyn Chiu Kumar.
Stanley Zhun-Lung Lam.
Abigail Vivian Lee.
Araceli A. Lopez.
Brandon Lu.
Thomas Duke Martin.
Matthew Bassam Massaad.
Phyllis Nokuthaba P. Mugadza.
Asante Paul Mzungu.
Gregory Connor Naratil.
Maggie K. Nolan.
Emily Eunjung Oh.
Samuel Brooks Calabresi.
Alice Park.
Jordan Christine Pilant.
William R. Polsky.
Ioann Popov.
Peter Prastakos.
Andrew James Rochon.
Catherine Jens Sawkins.
Bhavesh Sandeep Sayal.
Lara Schull.
Mei Shinomiya.
Olivia Shoemaker.
Vasileios Platon Sioufas.
Slater Adams Smith.
Kelly Ann Speltz.
Hristo Svetoslavov Staykov.
Henry Steven Suckow Ziemer.
James Jian Sun.
Martin Daly Tipton.
Teodora Angelova Tyankova.
Jenna Grace Van De Grift.
Ram Vishwanathan.
Aaron Joshua Wade.
Tom Wallenstein.
Kenneth Wang.
Xavier Tariq Washington.
Thomas Bailey Wiesler.
Jason Yang.
Jennifer Y. Yoon.
Dana Zamir.
And Maciej J. Zielonka.
The graduates participating remotely.
(upbeat music)
Congratulations, Silliman class of 2021.
(people cheering)
(bell ringing)
- Mr. President, I have
the honor to present
candidates from Ezra Stiles College
for the Bachelor's
degrees in Yale College.
When they have been
recommended by the faculty
of Yale College and
approved by the corporation,
Dean Chun will ask you
by your official act
to confer upon them these degrees.
(people cheering)
- By the authority vested in
me, I shall confer upon you
the Bachelor's degrees in Yale College,
when designated by the dean,
and shall than admit you
to all their rights and responsibilities.
- Covert James Geary, Jr,
the banner bearer of Ezra Stiles College.
Gabriella Blatt and Luta Fast Dog,
the procession marshals
of Ezra Stiles College.
Grace Ellen Aaronson.
Jacob Angelo Abdallah.
Zainab Omowonuola Eniola Abiola Odunowo.
Jack Adam.
Alessandra Sofia Aguirre.
Katherine Teresa Arackaparambil.
Bessie Maria Bauman.
Brittany Marie Bistis.
Sofia Eva Bliek.
Greta Kirby Browne.
Brandon Robert Canfield.
Martin Stuart Chandler.
Joseph Leo Class.
Alexander Nathan Cohen.
Nathaniel Alexander Cuevas.
Aivy T. Duong.
Ivy Victoria Fan.
Alyssa Nicole Firth.
Veronica E. Galimberti.
Raymond Liu Gao.
Simon Alexander Ghebreyesus.
Abigail Gertrude Gundrum.
Grant Theodore Halliday II.
Aloni Bennette Harris.
Charles Townsend Hardy Hawkings.
Jacqueline Vilas Mercedes Hayre-Pérez.
Philip Edward Hinkes.
Logan McClane Howard.
Cassandra Hsiao.
Katherine Hu.
Alejandro Antonio Jaco.
Emily Yuanwen Ji.
Emily Elizabeth Johnson.
Jaeger Mario Johnson.
Dayrin Meshach Lourome Jones.
Zachary Dakota Jones.
Alicia Rada Kacharia.
Yuki Kawamura.
Andrew Peter Kuzemczak.
Yoanna Petrova Lazarova.
Isabel Jinhee Lee.
Jin Li.
Emily Lin.
Laurence Da Xiao Lu.
Cameron Morgan Luther.
Sara Jane Luzuriaga.
Sabrina Lyz Macias.
Sam C. Maniscalco.
Tia Jacqueline Maresca.
Jever Kohli Mariwala.
Mary Clare McMahon.
Brittany Miranda Menjivar.
Kellen M. Mermin-Bunnell
Anna Graves Milliken.
Andi Mo.
Mohamed Hassan Mohamud.
Isabel Marie Monroy.
Vikram Mullick.
Sophia Jihye Nam.
Jose Navas.
Peter Nekrasov.
Max Daniel Nobel.
Alexandria Bella Noble.
Coral Lyn Ortiz.
Nolan Patrick Padin.
Marisa Alexis Peryer.
Kaley G. Pillinger.
Lorenzo Pinasco Ferreyros.
Andrew Jordan Vita Prinster.
Ivana Prstic.
Sajan Narayana Ramanathan.
Esther Reyes.
Kobe James Rizk.
Laurie Anne Roark.
Carolyn Elizabeth Jae Hee Sacco.
Isabel Salinas-Arreola
Emily Hope Schussheim.
Benjamin Cole Shelton.
Jovan Matthew Tafoya.
Helen S. Teegan.
Renee Jessica Tung.
Zachary Logon Wade.
Samantha Jimenez Westfall.
Nia Aderonke Whitmal.
Jonathan Wu.
Emily Han Xu.
Chethan Sanjay Yadav.
Alec Gray Zbornak.
Zixuan Oasis Zhen.
Benjamin Kaihua Zhou.
Cristofer Zillo.
And the graduates participating remotely.
(upbeat music)
Go Ezra Stiles.
(people cheering)
- To the students of the Class of 2021
and their parents, families and friends
looking on from around the globe,
we gather to recognize the
extraordinary accomplishments
of all of you who have worked so hard
to complete your programs of study.
We salute your efforts, your diligence,
your talent and your intellect.
We also join you in expressing gratitude
for all who have supported
you in these endeavors.
Your families and friends, teachers
and other members of the Yale community.
Congratulations Class of 2021.
(people cheering)
- Hello, Class of 2021.
My name is Steven
Orientale and I am a member
of the Class Day committee
and the Senior Class Council.
Four years have gone by
in the blink of an eye.
We've made so many memories
from the first year
snowball fight on Old Campus right here,
to the Yale-Harvard football game of 2019,
where we won in double overtime,
to all the late nights,
whether they be in a library
studying for an exam,
or in the common room
talking with our friends and teammates.
Although our senior year
experience was certainly
not a traditional one, the Class of 2021
made the best of the situation.
When we leave Yale in just
a few days, we will leave
with memories and friendships
that will last a lifetime.
Here's the class of 2021. We did it.
(people cheering)
- Class of 2021, good morning.
My name is Stanley Lam.
- And I'm Jin Li.
- And we are members of the committee
that organized Class Day, which will air
on YouTube tomorrow at 2:30 PM.
- Two minutes before 2:30 at 2:28 PM,
a special piece written
by our Class Day speaker
Robert Lopez will be
played from Harkness Tower,
so keep your ears open.
- If you haven't already
decorated a funny hat
for Class Day, it's not too late.
- In fact, on your seat
today, you received
a Class Day 2021 hat that
you might want to use
just for that purpose.
- You'll also find a gift
bag, which includes items
that represent long-standing
Class Day traditions,
as well as others that are new
and unique to the Class of 2021.
- In addition to the Class Day speaker,
tomorrow's program also includes remarks
by members of our class
who have put together
outstanding original speeches.
- And because Class
Day is about all of us,
you'll see your photographs
and video reflections
throughout tomorrow's program.
- Congratulations class of
2021, and see you at Class Day,
(people cheering)
- Class of 2021, congratulations again.
I am so happy to be with you
and to celebrate with you today.
Graduating is a great accomplishment,
one of the most important
ones of your life,
and if you think back to when
you first arrived on campus,
no one could have imagined
that you would live through
a global pandemic before
reaching this moment,
but you did, and thanks to
your strength and perseverance,
this moment has finally come.
I'm honored to recognize all
the work that you have done
to get here, much of it with
the support of your family
and friends, so today is your
day and it is theirs too.
Today is a day for looking back with pride
at everything you have accomplished
and all the goals you have reached.
Of course, it brings some sadness too,
now that you are ending
your bright college years.
But today is a commencement, a beginning,
so now as you look to
the days and years ahead,
think of the new achievements
and opportunities
in front of you and look around as well,
to remind yourself of
the excellent company
joining you on the new beginning,
your friendships formed at Yale.
Tomorrow you will celebrate
Class Day, a tradition
stretching back 150 years
in Yale College history.
I'm excited to watch the
virtual program along with you,
and on Monday, we can look forward
to President Salovey's
commencement address.
I'm grateful to the Class Day committee,
to the Senior Class
Council, to the University
secretary's office, to your
college heads and deans,
and to everyone who contributed to making
the special events of
this weekend possible.
And I'm most appreciative to you,
for all that you have brought to Yale
and will now bring out
into the world with you.
Again, Class of 2021, congratulations.
(people cheering)
(classical music)
(upbeat music)